manchmal tut es regnen oder schneien
wenn noch viel passieren geschaffen
hallo und herzlich willkommen zur
nächsten super show mit mal wanne wir
haben heute noch einen speziellen gast
der ab sofort immer da sein wird das ist
der kevin kevin willst du dich mal
selber vorstellen was mache ich hier
dieses video bei mir sind ja nicht nur
hier um über blaue stoffhasen zu
sprechen sondern möchte ich heute über
thema hashtags reden also erst mal eine
frage wie haben sich hashtags so schnell
verbreiten können
vor ein paar jahren kann sie noch keiner
und boom jeder benutzt hashtags überall
twitter facebook instagram im fernseher
werden erst ex benutzt auf plakaten in
werbungen und ich habe das gefühl ist
das irgendwie das neue
kommunikationsmittel wird vermittelt
dich über hashtags jetzt neu
natürlich würde ich mich niemals gegen
so einen trend wären sondern macht
einfach mit wie alle anderen auch meine
ich lebe in berlin also wenn ich nicht
jetzt trends folgen kann man dann also
ich hab mal geschaut was ich so für
hashtags benutze ich glaube richtig
trendy bin ich nicht damit habe ich zum
beispiel hashtags bundes geste galt
peschek draußen drehen ist kalt hashtags
so kalt hashtag wind der winter war und
zwar windig also wind her hast du
verstanden also im allgemeinen heißen
hashtags schlagwörter die etwas
verlinken sollen dafür sind sie da
für die leser nicht verstanden haben und
da ist zu viel zeit habe und mich mit
solchen dingen beschäftigen gibt es von
mir jetzt hashtags die mir auf den sack
geht und hashtags die man nicht auf den
sack gehen und her
6 bei denen ich die pure hassgefühle
bekomme mein herr staeck erster hashtag
ist hashtag food machen
mein hashtag erster hashtag ist herr
steckborn kommt klar damit also bei
hashtag food borne denke ich nicht an
leckeres essen sondern an eine banane
die mit einem ich zeige euch einfach mal
bilder ein zweiter hashtag ist dieses
herrscht etwas benutzt wenn du ein foto
von dir selber post ist und dann machst
du rein steckt viel drunter
wie konnte dieses wunderschöne wort
porträt wie konnte das zu diesem
schmutzigen kurzen wurzer figur bernd
schreiber hashtag nummer drei hashtag
long hair don't care gut man kann es
auch mit short herr don't care red herr
don't care linie airblue ermittlungen
her dort hast dich ja nett an aber
vorüber kehrst du nicht krieg long hair
don't care welthunger lang her don't
care deine zukunft lang her don't care
about meine zukunft man über kehrst du
denn nicht mein vierter hashtag #tatort
herr staeck gold qft girls girls girls
meine fresse hier kann das
wahrscheinlich wenn ihr auf einem foto
sei bei einem mädchen ein tattoo hat
mädchen hat am besten noch ein kreuz
oder unendlichkeit zeichen schmetterling
quad weiß ich jetzt passiert und dann
der hashtag kommt girls with no go tabus
dieses kleine ding ja was auch jemand
anderes mit dem kugelschreiber drauf
schreiben
bitte also bitte das war noch nicht
genug
bitte und ich habe tatsächlich einen
fünften hashtag #tatort
in den dreck wieso sollte ich clean
essen also sorry oder mir die hände
waschen wenn sie damit
was steht davor die hände hashtags und
dieser sechster hashtag ist ein versuch
von mir den leuten in der welt zu helfen
hashtag like for like nein es ist
einfach auf so vielen ebenen falsch
natürlich jeder möchte aufmerksamkeit
jeder möchte bewunderung und jeder
möchte irgendwo gesehen wären aber
herrscht like-for-like es ist die größte
scheiße dann gehst du auf ein anderes
profil um seine bilder zu leiten damit
diese personen dann auf dein profil geht
um deine bilder zu leiten
was habt ihr davon dass da jetzt 36
gefällt mir steht anstatt 12 dann nimmt
doch lieber diese zwölf gefällt mir an
und sieht es als etwas positives aber
sucht euch doch nicht leute die ihre
bilder leiten damit da mehr steht also
die leute die das machen ich habe euch
hört auf damit das zieht so dumm aus
dass das wirkt so weiß nicht ich reg
mich jedes mal wieder darüber auf und
dann war das auch schon meine gesprächs
einlage für heute und ich wünsche euch
einen wunderschönen tag nacht morgen
mittag was ihr gerade auch tut
und tschüss